I'm always fascinated when I'm on a Zoom
or a virtual meeting with somebody
and I look at their background. And I
always wonder
what are these items that this person
deemed important enough to be behind
them on their Zoom or virtual calls?
Their background setup. What are the
stories behind these items? And I want
to share a story with you about one of
the items you can see behind me,
which is these books. Let me grab them.
These books are the complete Speakers
and Toastmasters library.
And while I have been incredibly
passionate about public speaking for the
last 12 years,
I got these books long before I had any
interest in public speaking.
Several years ago, many years ago, my
grandpa passed away. And our family, my
relatives, we all went to his house
after the fact, and a lot of his items
were laid out. It was almost like a
garage sale set up in his basement. And
we each had a color of sticker that we
could put on items we were interested
in.
And I don't know what it was that drew
me to these. I had zero interest in
public speaking back then.
But I I put my sticker on on these
books.
And I've never really dove into them.
They're just sort of a decoration. But
it's funny looking back how my life
naturally took this course to joining
Toastmasters, to becoming passionate
about public speaking,
and these books were always there.
Last night I was I was looking in this
book, Speech Openers and Closers, and
just some interesting thoughts on
speaking. And there was a line that drew
my attention.
And the line was, "Speeches are like
giving birth.
Easy to conceive, challenging to
deliver."
What a great line, first and foremost.
This this historic wisdom on public
speaking.
But, I think that that ties into a
modern-day example.
A lot of people We're about to go from
from historical to to current day.
A lot of people are asking the question,
"What is going to become obsolete
because of AI? What skills is AI going
to completely take over?"
But, I think a more interesting question
is, "What existing skills are going to
have more value when AI is ubiquitous?"
And by the way, it feels like it's
almost ubiquitous as of right now. So
many people are using AI in many
capacities on a daily basis.
And one of the skills I think is only
going to get more and more and more
important is this age-old concept of
public speaking and in-person
communication.
Let me give you an example.
Digital communication is
especially when it comes to writing and
text is becoming quickly swallowed up by
AI.
So many of the emails I get in my inbox,
I just know they were written with AI.
How do I know that?
I can just tell, and you probably can,
too.
Emails that you've gotten so often from
a particular person that were
a various format or were a certain
format, and now
the text the first off, the font is
different. The text is built into these
structures that happen to be the same as
as what it looks like when you're using
chat GPT. This person who never used
emojis is using emojis. This person who
never used punctuation such as m dashes
is using m dashes in every sentence.
You can tell.
And that's fine.
I understand writing is challenging for
some people and that these AI tools help
them become quite a bit more efficient.
But I've also gotten kind of frustrated
because
the frequency and the depth of these
emails that are being generated by AI
are being sent my way with expectations
that I read and consume all that content
and then I deliver back my answers based
on all that information, which is quite
time-consuming.
And I don't know why it bugs me other
than knowing this particular person
other than a few prompts to AI
didn't write all of that information but
is asking me to take action and give my
thoughts.
Therefore, I've started using my AI
tools to read the information and then
to send a response on my behalf. And
what's happening here
is that it's just bots that are
communicating.
Sure, the bots are communicating on my
behalf. I am one of those AI users who
is putting a lot of time to ensure that
the bot understands my vision and my
values and how I communicate. So, it's
probably communicating effectively on my
behalf.
But when we really take a step back,
it's just bots communicating back and
forth.
And that is, as I mentioned, swallowing
up digital communication.
And we could see that this is having an
impact even on video content.
YouTube recently changed rules to its
creator partnership program, making it
much harder for people to enter that
program.
And what a lot of speculation is is that
those rules were changed because of the
overabundance of AI slop, as they call
it, AI generated videos and channels
that
are earning a lot of money because of
the content and the frequency
that they're putting out that content,
which is gaining views. And so they made
it a lot trickier to enter that creator
partnership, which who knows if this
will help that problem. In my mind, it's
not going to do a lot to help it.
Regardless, we know AI generated video
is only going to become more and more
common as well.
Which brings me back to the historic
wisdom here.
Speeches are are easy to conceive,
difficult to deliver.
Yes, AI can help us conceive a speech
idea.
It can build a structure for us. It can
allow us to have ideas and bring in
facts and and concepts.
But then when we walk in front of that
crowd
and it's just us,
that's the real test.
Because at this point in time, maybe
when the actual physical robots are
here, it might change.
But right now, people want to see a
human deliver information.
And I could sit there and read
everything that the AI
tool has provided me with,
but that's not engaging.
That's not going to win over an
audience.
It's up to me to deliver that
information in a way that can inspire
that audience.
Or in that one-on-one conversation,
to still have the listening skills, to
be able to use my brain to make those
connections, to respond in a way that is
helpful to that other person.
And so this skill of human communication
in person
in my mind is more important than ever.
It's always been a valuable skill, but
AI's evolution and the rise in AI is
making this skill set even more
important. So if you have thought about
working on your public speaking skills,
I
implore you, I push you to do that
because I think now is a more important
time than ever.
People are going to be able to be caught
out pretty quickly. Those people who are
hiding behind the keyboards having AI do
a lot of the work on their behalf when
they are in person and they are asked
questions,
the skill set of our brains, our ability
to leverage impromp- impromptu speaking,
even prepared speeches, and deliver in a
way that showcases we understand the
information, and we know how to inspire
the audience, that is going to be so
incredibly important.
So this age-old wisdom
still has a place today.